and now as long as the uh the angle has
really wondered for a long time
when will New England decide to save
itself when States like Maine Rhode
Island Connecticut finally get fed up
with high taxes low growth Rising crime
when they finally kick the Democrat
dinosaurs into the Amber well then when
that happens we'll see how populism is
really taking hold well I was in
Connecticut over the weekend I have more
on that later for my Glastonbury High
School reunion I spent a lot of time
talking to folks on the ground there a
lot of people seemed really fed up and
we're both sad and mad at what had
happened to the state we all grew up in
and I sense the Democrats who once
thought that they were Untouchable in
the state I'm talking about elected
officials may be starting to sweat it
Republicans are actually spending money
in these races across the region a Kevin
McCarthy aligned pack is spending 23
million dollars on ads and eight
Democratic held districts that Biden
carried by double digits in New England
now some interesting nuggets here in
Connecticut's 5th congressional district
were Biden won by 11 Republican George
Logan is demonstrating broad bipartisan
appeal according to axios and in Rhode
Island's second where Biden won by 14 a
new poll has Republican Alan Fung
leading the Democrat by eight points
so how bad are things in New England
well in New Hampshire where liberal
Senator Maggie Hassan is running away
from any debates it's Fentanyl and the
economy that's killing them
there is there is a drug problem around
here I mean there's a lot of there's a
lot of that that goes on but that's
because there's not a lot going on
around here there's not a lot of work
around here there's not a lot of jobs
around here thank you globalization and
in Massachusetts and Rhode Island some
folks will be choosing between food or
heat this winter
we're seeing electricity prices rise in
New England we've seen electricity
prices go up increase over 64 percent in
Massachusetts and Rhode Island
in Maine things are no better
we always hear from our struggling
neighbors friends and family members
about winter and how hard it is
specifically older mainers but we've not
heard concern what we like we are
hearing this year and what we're hearing
is um we don't know how we're going to
make it we simply can't afford these
costs
oh it's infuriating in Connecticut crime
is out of control flags were at half
staff this weekend that was after three
police officers were ambushed two were
dead more than 80 rounds were fired at
them from behind
it was multiple rounds and it was like
war zone and then next thing you knew
there were Sirens flying everywhere and
it was just it was scary it was actually
scary because we don't get this we don't
have this this is a quiet neighborhood
not anymore no one is safe no wonder the
state's incumbent Democratic senator Ned
no answer is Lamont is in a tight race
with Republican Bob stefanovski
on nutmeggers it's time to try something
different you've done this forever and
one woman who wants to help lead the
charge is leor Levy she's trying to
unseat that septuagenarian Senator
serpent Richard Blumenthal a new
Connecticut examiner for rizio poll has
her only down by five points Leora joins
me now Leora good to see you I felt the
fear building over the weekend in the
State uh people are scared so my
question is what have Democrats done for
Connecticut lately
well all the Democrats have done for
Connecticut lately is to make life
unaffordable
to make life feel unsafe their crime has
risen to make Connecticut a border state
by flying illegals to Westchester County
Airport and to Tweed airport bringing
Fentanyl and human trafficking and all
the other things that's what the
Democrats have done for us here and the
people of Connecticut are ready for
change
I am so happy to hear you were in
Glastonbury I was in Glastonbury
yesterday at the Apple Festival
yeah I can't believe I missed you that
stuff I'm sorry I missed you too well
but it's a great state Leo it's this is
this is actually a wonderful state if
people haven't spent time in New England
you just kind of write it off so it's
liberal but it's beautiful you're great
people and I think we we have to have a
mantra no State Left Behind there's no
reason Connecticut has to be in this
situation none at all
that's right life does not have to be
this way we can change it can feel
normal again we're not asking for
extravagances we just want to be able to
feed our kids
heat our homes go to work with a full
tank of gas and not think twice about it
that is not too much to ask and and and
we can change it's time to change and
I'm the woman that's going to bring
change to Connecticut uh Leora you're so
courageous and brave to be doing what
you're doing but you have big money on
the other side and that's Senator
Richard Blumenthal who was most recently
expressing frustration at Saudi Arabia
for not bailing out the Democrats on the
high gas prices watch this humongous
blunder by the Saudis that is against
their own self-interest as well as the
threat to the global economy the danger
of rising oil prices to American
consumers at the pump it harms Americans
and I think that the administration
more than any of us is well aware of
these practical consequences
Leora if there ever were a worthless U.S
senator Richard Blumenthal is he
disgust me to hear him say that given
our energy glut that we have in this
country and what we've done to our own
people Connecticut just for that they
should vote against him just for that
comment
I agree with you and I want to remind
people he's a senator who voted for the
jcpoa the last Iran agreement and he
will do it again
he is threatening the Saudis by saying
what he said and by the way he only
wanted to do for them to delay their
reduction in production by one month so
he could win the election he doesn't
care about the people of Connecticut but
I do I want to reinvigorate American
energy production so we can bring those
prices down again permanently and I'd
love people to go to my website
leora4ct.com to learn more about me and
learn more about the policies I will be
promoting Ms Levy we need a female
Connecticut Senator conservative with
smart Solutions this is all about common
sense and you got it uh good luck
everyone in Connecticut get out and vote
and change hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else